he is the quarterback for the Detroit
Lions Matthew Stafford back on the
program good morning Matthew how are you
morning Dan doing it hurry but we were
talking about the show friends and we
just noticed that one of your children
is named Chandler mm-hmm is Chandler
named after Chandler Bing from friends
no unfortunately not oh that's a family
name for my wife so a good character no
doubt but didn't make the cut for why we
named her all right well thanks for
coming on that's all we wanted to talk
to you what is it like with the kids
when you come home after a game it's
honestly a blast that's my favorite part
win lose draw doesn't matter you know I
come home and and they're running up to
me it's I usually work days
I'm usually getting home about a half
hour before bedtime so I get to hang
with him for about 30 minutes which I
you know it's probably just the right
amount of time and but I get to hang
with him for that and then put him down
and you know hang out the rest the night
but it's awesome they're they're blessed
okay does your wife Kelly then let them
know dad had a bad day or go easy on no
it's it's full on let it rip when I get
home but I'm always happy to see him too
it's uh you know they post my little
face pretty easily so it's it's fun
do you watch do you follow what's going
on with these other quarterbacks breeze
and surgery Ben's out for the year with
surgery daniel Jones cuz just got named
starter with the Giants you follow the
quarterback in carousel yeah I do a
decent amount um you know always just
trying to see what other guys are doing
how they're playing you know how they're
leading their teams all that kind of
stuff the injuries were really
unfortunate there's been quite a few you
know you know early on in this season
bunch of guys either getting you know
obviously the Jets every guys sick and
the next guy gets hurt I mean they're
down to three it was kind of a tough
weekend for quarterbacks but yeah I pay
attention to it I'm just happy that so
far this year have been pretty healthy
do you play not to get hurt can you can
you possibly play that way no I don't
think so not at all every once in a
while you got to be smart and sliding on
out of bounds that's the best thing you
can do but most the time you're just
going out there letting it rip trying to
do anything can help your team one
how do you play differently now let's
say five years ago or have the rules
allowed you to play differently I think
I think I play about the same I try this
you know learn as much as I can from
five years to now but and try and play
smarter but not always the case but now
I don't think there's much of a
difference obviously I think they're
protecting players all across the field
not only the quarterbacks you know as
much as they possibly can and I think
that's good for the games you guys can
be healthy and play week in and week out
but as far as my attitude towards the
game it's the same what's the best
audible word that you've had oh my gosh
anything that makes you laugh when you
say it no I try not to use those there's
been quite a few that have been close
and we've had some ideas during the week
but never good when the offensive line
is chuckling before we say setup so we
try to lock it in and keep it serious I
don't know if you could have this
audible this weekend against the Eagles
I don't know if you take suggestions or
not what do you got for me okay Matt
Ryan is gonna use one of my guys names
McLovin who works on the show in his
game against the Colts now fritzy fritzy
who always reaches out to book you at
least once a year he's the one you you
talked to so I don't know if you get to
the line of scrimmage against the Eagles
and just feel comfortable enough to go
I'll see what I can do maybe it's just a
dummy audible for us you know well
that's what he used for us exactly
that's what I figured it was it was
perfect but alright alright I mean
that's not asking too much I don't think
right I don't think so yeah yeah if you
ask me to do something on my show and it
could be a reference to you your family
your kids you know something I would do
that for you just to let you know I know
when you go to line of scrimmage you got
other thing like if Chandler did well in
school I'd be more than happy to you
know give her a show her report card or
something did you know when you were
coming out of high school was it you and
Tebow the two top quarterbacks
yeah he was in my class yeah we were we
were
both up there there were a few other
guys for sure Josh Freeman was up there
Jevons need a couple other guys but yeah
Tebow was a was a superstar for sure
when we were when we were young okay but
that was competition like did you you
know were you keeping an eye on what
Tebow was doing
I really wasn't like super into high
school football and like rankings and
where people were going to college I
know that sounds dumb that's especially
the way there's nowadays with kids
getting scholarships at you know ten
years old it seems like but I was just
kind of focused on my team and let the
kind of chips fall where they may I
guess yeah I'm wondering I mean it's so
crazy if it wasn't Georgia where were
you gonna go I don't know you know I was
grew up in Texas so Texas was up there
for sure both my parents went to Florida
State so I want to go to Florida State
there for a little bit those were
probably the other two that I was
seriously considering how are the Lions
how do you feel about this team good I
feel good you know obviously a weak one
can't wait with a tie which was
unfortunate I thought we played well we
just didn't finish the game and then you
know this past week I think it was a
little bit of you know the opposite
where we didn't play as well but we
finished the game and I got a win
against the charger so that was a big
one for us at our place anytime you went
at home it's big in this league and then
obviously got a big one coming up this
week against Philly at their place
really talented team so it'll be a
little bit good challenge for us but
what's that like to walk off the field
with the time it's honestly the first
time I've tied in a football game ever I
think I was trying to think back and
remember maybe we all got orange slices
and Capri Suns when I was you know seven
years old and we tied but it's been a
long time since that and it was it was
kind of a weird feeling I imagine you
know for the Cardinals that it probably
felt like more of a win and for us a
little bit more of a loss just
considering we were ahead to most of the
game they did a great job of coming back
and we kind of didn't do a good job
finishing so it was a it was a sour
taste but it was nice to come out and
get a win you know that week after that
but if I said let's settle this you and
Kyler Murray let's see who can throw it
the farthest I don't know kids got a
pretty big on he's young healthy I
prefer him taking the L in a 40-yard
dash could he outrun if he ran backwards
Matthew could he beat you on the floor
later
[Laughter]
how fast is he because I always tell my
guys when you watch on the sidelines
it's a completely different game when
you're watching on TV it looks so easy
and guys you can't really tell how fast
they are and you know strong it's wild
I always tell people if you until you
watch the game from the sidelines you
don't you don't understand just because
you I mean you hear it to the vital
sidelines and everything I mean it's
it's a violent game and guys are running
around flying but he's for sure way
faster than me and when we played him he
looked I don't know four four four three
he was rolling I would not have I would
never have played or had my kids play if
I was down on the sidelines and you
watch that and hear those collisions and
they aren't you here it is I guess
there's no way I'd let my kid play yeah
I mean I understand people that say that
you know that wouldn't you know I think
it's it's an individual decision no
question I mean I understand both ways
that's a great game given me a lot you
know I've loved every minute of it had
some great experiences got to experience
a bunch of stuff that I probably would
have never experienced but at the same
time it's it's a toll on your body and
you know it's it's a tough tough
decision to make
he's Matthew Stafford got the Eagles on
the road I'll leave you with this if you
had stayed with baseball finishing
sentence I would probably be riding
around on a bus and the minors right now
hacking it for about right above the
Mendoza line and trying to play
shortstop for third it would have been
pretty it wouldn't have been pretty but
no I loved playing but I picked the
rights for it yeah but you throw harder
than Clayton does right no he's better
he's a better pitcher I wasn't like it
of a pitcher I was more of a shortstop
catcher third baseman kind of guy but I
don't think I would hit good enough to
you know to really play so you're not
alone there I developed a knuckleball
maybe and stuck around for a while that
was it if they didn't let him throw
breaking balls I would have been okay
it's those damn breaking balls Matthews
good luck against the Eagles always
great to have you and hope the family as
well
remember it's fritzy fritzy on the honor
board dummy ah I got it thank you God
for more Dan Patrick show tune in the
audience channel 239 on DirecTV stream
for free on BR live or download the Dan
Patrick show app
[Music]